[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we
want
i feel like i haven't seen you in a year
long time what you've been up to it's
been a minute
nothing eating i think that's what
everyone else is doing
you ain't craving getting a lot of food
huh bruh
bruh what's the first restaurant you
went to when you could get back into a
restaurant
the first restaurant i went to oh man it
was a
it was a wasted experience because it
was bad so i don't even think i want to
say the name
because it was trey's choice um look it
was it was
actually wait it was what it was just
something that's in our
area that we were always like we should
try that place once and then as soon as
we
was like let's try that place why didn't
you go to a place you were you were
you've been feeding for why did you go
to a new one i mean because
i was already getting that post made it
to me so it's not like i was missing out
but
now i was like okay let's go in there we
can't and yeah
they're not the same though getting
postmates and eating there that's true
uh okay it depends on how far away it is
oh also very true yeah also very true
well fud doesn't taste very good
pulse made it you gotta stretch the
noodles out
because it's been clumped together and
then you break the noodles in half and
[ __ ] they need to figure out what better
way to deliver burgers too
burgers burgers delivered as well it's
probably very delivery well if you you
get like i'm not talking about like uh
like burger king or whatever like
because you expect that to be not great
yeah i'm talking about like getting like
one of those sick ass big burgers like a
restaurant burger yeah a restaurant
burger
what part of the restaurant burger
delivery experience does not fulfill
your
the lettuce is always wilty the bread is
mushy
you know i have had burger places
deliver in a separate container
the vegetables what that's smart yeah i
forgot where but they gave me the tomato
and the lettuce in a separate container
and then the buns and meat and all that
stuff and another one
that has to be done yeah but then it's
not fresh so i'd prefer if they give it
the tomato and then
and then it comes with a knife
i want the butler to come and deliver it
to him like hand slice it
yeah i get to peel it and then put it
inside and then the cow shows up for you
to milk it and make the cheese and [ __ ]
and kill it and make the burger yeah
perfect that's like hello fresh but like
farm to house yeah but i don't want to
spend 30 minutes either so i got
something in between
there's no pleasing here that's like the
three
three rules in filmmaking thing right
where it's like you want it fast do you
want it uh
cheap yeah good or do you want to cheat
yeah or something like that yes you only
have two you can't have it cheap
not if you want it good fast what about
the blair witch that was quite good
was it fast i just don't remember it it
was cheap it was cheap it was cheap i
don't know apparently activity then the
first one makes
that a stupid amount of money yeah and
it's all like websites that was cheap
too and they made up like 35 grand
yeah i don't know if it was fast though
no [ __ ] way
but we definitely don't know as well
and we're not gonna look it up so let's
speculate let's just keep speculating oh
just continue speculating that'll
that'll definitely that won't set the
internet off what about you guys first
restaurant something you couldn't
[ __ ] wait to get back to i've been
violating quarantine so
i don't know about you guys i think mine
was a korean barbecue
yeah battered shaboo yeah shabu and
cream barbecue i
really miss just like freshly cooked
meat right in front of me
and that was dope i just went to states
that allowed me to go into restaurants
because i'm bougie like that yeah just
kidding i did that by accident i didn't
know how was that on accident he
accidentally went to the state and he
accidentally went
it does sound like a joke like travel
plan though i walked in and i was like
wait a minute this is a couch how do i
get here
it is crazy going to another state where
the rules are way different i remember
we went to utah
like end of year last year where they
don't give
a [ __ ] and then you're just like oh
[ __ ] like you go in a restaurant and you
have a mask on it when's that looking at
you
oh i don't wear this like you have the
disease
yeah like this guy has it yeah it's just
crazy they shame you for wearing a mask
and in la they shame you without wearing
a mask yeah even the gym in utah
no one was wearing a mask working out
but even the homeless people here wear
masks wait did you say no one was even
working out
no no one's gonna mask working out okay
that would be pretty great that'd be
weird
they weren't even working out show them
to a gym and you're just like they're
all just sitting there like on the bench
just like
that i feel like there'd be like a gym
in georgia
it's like everyone's just hanging out
nobody's gone somebody's drinking a beer
with a mask on
it's just drips but now no one's wearing
a mask like california
yeah and now people are getting a little
comfortable walking around it's getting
interesting
like i'm cool with you know if you don't
want to wear messes fine whatever i'm
not really usually wearing a mask when i
walk around the streets
but now people just walk really close to
you yeah i don't really like that
do you remember it or not i was gonna
say did you like that beforehand though
like someone gets a little too close to
me i got like kind of like dude please
just not walk so close to me you know
and they're just walking shoulder to
shoulder and the sidewalk is
very large there's space for everybody
very large yeah but people still want to
get really close
to buffing you're taking her too much to
the sidewalk yeah i wish right i don't
like this [ __ ] guy dude
like you got two of them together he
takes up half the [ __ ] table dude
yeah but he's not buff up or down at all
just side to side
[ __ ]
i'm going to show up to the gym and just
like being very toxic helps people grow
you know what i mean
that's what you got to do everyone's on
the internet is hella tall
[Laughter]
what's the place that you guys go to
that you're still kind of uncomfortable
this
like you guys do you guys take uber's
drag off mustache oh
nevermind can you wear a mouse please
before we jack me off can you wear masks
is it hotter when the girls wear masks
i don't know that's a that's an orange
interesting kink
it's like it's like i'll see you before
this i never got
horny from a dental hygienist but for
some reason
hold on dental hygienists man they
turned me
on for gas masks i never got it before
but now i get it
that's some burning man vibes i went to
the movie theater during the past i did
that [ __ ] was
dope what'd you watch we saw a quiet
place too oh cool and it was a
like you forget how being in a movie
theater how much better it is
than watching your [ __ ] living room
especially that boy you're like oh [ __ ]
like you really feel
everything right and then the way they
set it up was like every
four seats would be another party of of
people so in the whole theater there was
like 10 people
so it was where they all shut the [ __ ]
up do they all shut the [ __ ] up yeah
everybody was quiet good
we're all sitting down dude you get like
they said like wear masks but nobody
gave a [ __ ] if you're wearing a mask
inside because you know
they did the ear hanging thing where
they just keep constantly eating popcorn
it's like i got
i'm gonna put it on right after that
nobody even was thinking about putting
on a mask all right just throw them on
the ground and that was before
yeah yeah yeah you're putting mine on
yeah and that was that was before the
mass mandate was lifted in california so
it was great
i had such a good time during it i was i
was in a public restroom and i saw
a guy wearing a mask take a piss and
then just walk out without any water and
i'm like
you don't wash your hands it's just like
[ __ ] the mask is not on your hands you
care about this
you don't care about [ __ ] all your
[ __ ] pea hands yeah maybe covet
doesn't exist on a dick that's true
that's what i heard it's not an ingress
point for for for code or
when people wear masks and they wear it
under their nose and it's like yo
either take it off or leave it on yeah
put it all the way on or take it all the
way up
what's wrong with this i don't know it's
just like doesn't it isn't it supposed
to
same [ __ ] coming out you know yeah but
also just at that point
just take it off that's how i feel you
might as well just not wear it they
don't want to get yelled at
that's true when some people will go on
like for your nose
yeah people get mad at everybody now
yeah i haven't seen that in person yet
though so that's good
that hasn't been a that hasn't been a
social anxiety that i've had to endure
yet
i see tycho play at the park and then
his hands are like all like
dirty they lick him and then he go no he
goes and the pantry comes back
and he grabs some snacks and i'm like i
probably should tell him to wash his
hands
but i'm like but this is how you build
immunity so he's just eating chips
he's healthy so far we're going to take
his hands like rub him on the ground
before dinner
dude he's going to have a weird complex
doing that and then you
eat out of the same chip bag there's
like
rocks and gravel that's the texture bro
dude what's hilarious is uh i'm teaching
him how to wipe his ass right now cool
you have to get him ready
for school this will he uh so what
the process that we do is he has to wipe
his ass first
danny comes and tells me and i come and
check yeah and
uh the other day he wrapped around his
finger and like i'm just
in the kitchen i just see him go papa
like something crazy happened i'm like
what happened
i go into the batman goes look and
there's the toilet paper's around his
hand and he has dookie all up on his
finger
and i'm like did he wrap it around where
the fingers are exposed
gloves and he [ __ ] wiped his ass his
[ __ ] dookie all over here and he's
like
don't worry we're like hey that's all
you kid
hey you gotta fix your [ __ ] dude that's
great it's closer for me
i know go get some snacks now did you
teach him how to clean
or did he did did he do himself no i
just
like it it has to take i realize
teaching a kid more complex things
takes like 20 tries wiping ass is
complex it's complex dude you got it
there's there's technique bro you got to
do like
inch by inch by inch by inch he just
pinched fighting but
just getting it further up the handle
well because the other day
uh the other day where he over
compensated because i guess you know he
covers his
his hand so his arm was mummied this
time yeah
it was pretty much the whole roll of
toilet paper was in the toilet bowl
and he tried flushing it and now it's
like all the way at the top so it's hard
to explain
these things like so this is how
drainage works you can't you know you
just gotta go like
okay i'll try to troubleshoot this way
and a little bit of this way and
eventually when he's like nine he might
get it but he's going to the bathroom
right now like he's going in there
pooping in the toilet flush he doesn't
fall inside no he'll like he'll go
you're like papa i gotta go kaka i'm
like go do it and let me know
and uh we're gonna have to go pee pee
there there has been twice where
uh we we are in a public setting
and just randomly i look over and just
see his butt cheeks hanging out
because his pants are his ankle because
he's just peeing i'm like no no
[Laughter]
that's not on him at all you've
conditioned him to be like this is
socially acceptable
we can only do this at home not when
we're [ __ ] out
out and about but you know at home you
have a bathroom
right yeah but sometimes it's you
haven't seen this house bro
you're in the backyard and you're just
having fun it's easier to just do it
real quick yeah where's geo
i don't know exactly she has no idea
you're peeing in the yard again
if she sees this she's gonna be pissed
when you go out and get your nails done
there's [ __ ] no order at home dude
there's all these like patches of dead
grass
everywhere have you you taught him how
to courtesy flush
what's curtis after you drop the log
this [ __ ] guy bro
caveman do it a step out of time what is
it yeah but that's wasting water at
least you have three hands to your house
you're teaching them the ways to water
that's true but sometimes the smell is
like kind of worth it you know
i guess he does like flushing toilets
hey
like if he washes it if he sees me
peeing he'll go pop i want to do it i'm
gonna go ahead and he'll flush it
i think like seeing it go like down or
something that's awesome it's not the
pressing buttons or levers
yeah little kids like pressing buttons
and turning levers and [ __ ] i don't know
that's how i was just kidding i was like
oh this button got a present you got to
turn the light switches off and off one
time went to go eat at the red rock
casino or
the elevator and this was like you know
the uh this
was it an elf right where willful just
hits all the buttons
and then he gets out of the elevator
he's like
that goes just going [ __ ] ham on all
the buttons i'm like oh [ __ ] i feel bad
for whatever you have to give
wait you can't stop him you don't like
hey don't do that no i think like
dads have like uh uh reaction time is
slow
no you were you shut the [ __ ] up you
were laughing you're just getting
[ __ ] funny
i remember we went to get tacos it was
bart's turn and then [ __ ] taika gets
on the ground and he just starts
swimming in dirt oh and he picks up an
old coke bottle and then bar like hey
stop that [ __ ] and then he gets dirt and
[ __ ] starts putting it in and shaking
that [ __ ]
and he's covered in [ __ ] dirt and
then bart's like has just what dads do
yeah
all dads reactions guy walks into the
elevator afterwards and bart's like
dad's huh and the guy's like i'm a
[ __ ] dad [ __ ] you i don't know i'm
teaching my kid this [ __ ]
i feel like i do the same [ __ ] though
i'm just like all right [ __ ]
god i guess i gotta do laundry well it
sounds exhausting like
what bart said papa papa and then your
hands covered in poop and you have to
deal with like five minutes of getting
poop all over off of his hands
and i think like if you like laughing
and being in the moment sometimes you're
just so caught up in it you forget
you're supposed to like
clean it be a parent yeah you know what
snaps you out real quick though cleaning
poop on something
oh this is real i have to i have to
clean this now did you look at it for
like a couple minutes and be like what
the [ __ ]
should i do well like how do i how do i
clean this hand like what's the best way
to attack this
no i just we went to the sink and then i
wanted to watch both hands
and so there's like a lot of like
questions that people ask that you don't
have answers to yeah so i'm already put
both your hands on these things like no
only this one this one that's poo poo
and i'm like no you got to wash both
hands he's like why
all right i don't know that's true you
only have [ __ ] on this hand
do it this is first like pulling his
hand out he's like no no i only want to
wash his head i'm like no you gotta wash
both of them
and then we end up washing both hands
but he's so traumatized no wash both
hands i don't need to
i cleaned this hand first and this was
clean already i'm like let's just double
check and do both hands but i don't know
how to explain all that [ __ ] to a kid
so i watched both hands now he's just
traumatized he's like daddy made me
watch the clean hand
and now he's just like sitting there the
whole time he's he's standing there like
this
yeah everything's a delayed reaction
he's just there for like two minutes
what did you do wash his
fingers first and then his ass cause
like he's sitting there with
dookie all over his butt with kaka on
his finger i don't think there's dukie
on his butt anymore bro
the first thing i did was transfer his
butt so he's like this
and i think he had diarrhea too so i was
like wiping his ass he goes
slow
because it popping because it [ __ ]
hurts yes i used baby wipes and i
cleaned that and then afterwards and i
took him to the sink and washed his hand
and i watched both that's [ __ ]
hilarious bro
you ready for that no it's pretty
interesting
being like you guys are next man pretty
interesting dude
yeah probably it's a lot of fun times
when do you learn when do you teach him
to use the bidet
the bidet we don't ours didn't have a
day yeah it's not a big day we had on
our old house but we didn't connect to
you
so why did you do it that way and not
throw him in the shower and [ __ ] hold
him down
oh he was downstairs wasn't a shower
downstairs
and you get poop on the shirt you take
it up throw this away you don't need
those anymore
he's taking care of kids before he does
i just [ __ ] on my hand
you guys are next man are you gonna have
kids no you're sure
you already said it my girlfriend's a
lot younger than me so it's like i have
a kid already
do you ever gonna get your tubes tied um
nah man
we might end up having a kid like when
i'm old as [ __ ] and when she's a normal
kid have an age yeah yeah yeah um
[Laughter]
yeah i mean neither of us are interested
right now she got a lot going on
career-wise
i don't want to do that so we're in
agreement
not right now that's good that's a good
sweet spot that's true because you would
be the one watching
the kaka all day while she's out there
doing a food channel or something yeah
exactly i can't take care of [ __ ] i have
to cook
steve are you thinking about having kids
soon we were firmly
stopped we stopped trying for like a
year just during all this [ __ ]
too stressful uh well yeah just covered
we didn't want to go to a hospital
all that kind of [ __ ] so we were just
like [ __ ] it we'll we'll be
careful and all that but now we started
back up like last week
wow damn data steve
man that's crazy well we we hung out
with my little
cousins and my my nieces and all the
mini greens yeah the little greens and
little
limos and we we we wanted to do it again
after that but before that we were like
[ __ ] this absolute [ __ ]
for like a good year that's a good
indicator yeah i get the opposite
i play with the kids and as soon as some
[ __ ] goes wrong i'm like
okay i'm reminded why i don't want
that's how i feel the very beginning i'm
like yeah
kids all back i have one right and then
they're just like oh
[ __ ] yeah once this year handle it
that volume is correlated with me not
wanting to have kids
but that was the best part about like
like being there with the kids was
getting to hand it off and then leave
and then back
isn't that what grandparents like
favorite part is it's just like oh yeah
we get to spell you oh you're having a
fit
yeah yep here's your mom not my parents
though my parents are like
full-time like wet nurses over there oh
their work they're
they're actually they like it though or
they love it they love kids and like i
think for my dad
he didn't get to hang with us much when
i was growing up so i think he's like
making up for lost time with himself
do you think you guys would be doing
that is like moving close to family so
you get back up and all that
yeah [ __ ] yeah it takes a lot of work
man i see it like with my family like
you have gio's mom like i bet you'd be
so screwed without her
we don't have her right now and it's
tough yeah it's really tough
and christina don't leave the house yeah
exactly yeah dude and every time i see
aunt he's like don't have kids bro
i came over conversations not about that
at all
and then jeremy came over they came over
last week right
and jeremy has a baby i have taika and
he has two kids
the chicks decided to go out and do
their [ __ ] right so it's cool
and then tyka's the oldest so he's
actually like
pretty easy or like he seems kind of
tired i'm like hey take a nap right now
okay so he just knocked out i'm like i
did have to check out for a little bit
and then jeremy's baby it's only like
four months old
so she's nap time anyways so jeremy's
like
and then has these two kids and you just
see them go oh [ __ ]
one wants to eat the other one's running
around the other one knows how to walk
too now so they're just like
he climbs bro he gets on my bed and
starts jumping i'm like what the [ __ ]
get down from there
yeah he's a monkey yeah i'm just like
[ __ ] he got like he's getting like
double teamed by like
lebron and shaquille o'neal at the same
time and i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's like we tried to help them out
but i'm like damn two
is yeah it's like when they're together
they're tornado
yeah because like i hear them from the
background one
like a [ __ ] mosquito right i'm like
oh they're coming
straight into my room they go to my
[ __ ] piano bang bang bang bang
[ __ ] guitar get on my bed jump jump
jump
it sounds like you're in the room yeah
i'm i'm
actually with them and i'm like my
friends are here
all that [ __ ] say you did it
we have a band perfectly calm right and
then [ __ ] the
one of the kids for some reason just
wants to slap the other one
hmm that baby starts crying this baby
slaps us when now they're both crying
they're like
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it was just perfectly
calm just one second ago
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you